hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the
uh euro oprah rapid chess tournament
it's magnus carlson versus uh 2018 usgs
champion sam
shankland and this game just shows how
easy it is to break basic chess
principles and then how good things
happen when you do that so magnus has
the white pieces
and he opens with c4 and already the fun
starts with c6 so sort of a karo khan
system against the english and now
magnus goes for the move from the
thumbnail and that's queen to a4 and it
looks like a
really really weird idea and to tell you
the truth i have no idea
what what this is all about uh but
probably something to use to confuse
your opponent
in a rapid game but who knows maybe it's
even perfectly fine because
nowadays uh there are no uh
anti-positional moves there are no
uh you know principled moves so anything
goes today in the era of engine so queen
to a4
uh and uh shankland of course uh
responds in a very principled manner he
just continues
development knight to f6 knight to f3 by
magnus and now
g6 he wants to play bishop g7 castle and
continue development and now
there are some games where knight to c3
and g3 were played but here magnus goes
for d4
and it's uh already as of move four that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how shankland deals with this we've
uh bishop to g7
and now knight to c3 we have castles and
now uh bishop therefore so just nicely
developing pieces
uh d6 and now h3 taking away the g4
square from
uh black slide square bishop we have
knight beat to d7
and now rook to d1 so again
going for a very nice development but
carlson's king is still on e1 and uh
it will take a few more moves for uh for
him to castle we have c5
uh striking in the center here uh hoping
for probably hoping for something like
d5 and then he can go for the bishop
here on f4 maybe
bishop h2 f5 and then it's going to be
very hard for
for white to develop the e4 square is
covered and
black black solved all of his problems
here so here instead magnus goes for e3
he just prepares to develop the light
square bishop
c captures on d for e captures and now
e5
shanklin strikes in the center we have
captures captures and now
bush back to e3 and now he uh furthers
the expansion with
e4 so carlson needs to do something
about this knight he plays knight to d4
and now queen to e7 adding another
defender to the knight here and also
just continuing development
uh we have bishop to e2 and now knight
to c5 attacking carlson's queen here on
a4
queen back to c2 and now bishop to d7 so
uh it's uh it's looking a bit funny this
queen to a4 idea going back to c2
but for the moment white's position is
perfectly fine and uh
once carlson castles is going to be a
very nice position for him
so here uh we have castles by magnus and
now comes
rook a to c8 and now knight d
the b5 so asking what do you want to do
about the undefended a7 pawn here
and shank one decides to eliminate the
knight as this light square bishop isn't
uh really doing all that much
so bishop captures the other knight
captures and now
a6 chasing away the knight and now
knight to d6 putting
pressure on the rook on c8 rook to c6 by
shankland and now
b4 by magnus and already we have the
critical moment of the game
uh what would you play in this position
uh just uh just a very short question
you don't need to pause the video just
what does your instinct tell you so
usually we say the
strongest move is a move with the knight
back however this position is the
exception here instead of going back
with the knight we should go
forward and then good things might
happen because now we're
threatening to pick up the knight here
and if the knight captures to eliminate
the defender of this knight then it's
not a problem knight captures we're
going to capture on d3 and black will
pick up the pawn here
white will still be better of course he
he can gain a lot of activity here with
rook to d7 rook to d1
the c pawn is defended but it is the
best course of action for black however
after this before move shankland said
uh all right i often heard that the
strongest move is the move with the
knight back and played knight c
to d7 but like we said this is an
exception and here magnus just played
c5 and now you will see how difficult it
is for black to make a move here
so what do you play here here franklin
goes for b6 of course you need to
challenge this
pawn here as it's uh creating a
beautiful outpost for the knight here
but now
queen returns to a4 once again so
carlson doesn't play queen a4 once but
twice so attacking that knight on rook
on c6 and also the pawn on a6 tonight
has to go back to defend both of them
and now the situation on the clock is
magnus has some 12 and a half minutes
whereas
shanklin has eight minutes so a
shankling burning time a lot faster
uh rook to d2 magnus doesn't really have
any
uh anything to worry about so he's just
gonna double up on the d
file and see what happens we have knight
f to d7 now
opening up the dark square bishop also
the knight can now come into the game
you can maybe shift the knight over to
d3 if possible
but now magnus just says nope not
happening knight
captures an e4 and it looks like magnus
overlooked the piece but
that couldn't be further from the truth
because if the knight is captured then
bishop f3
comes with an attack on the queen and
the rook is also on c6 and if the queen
defense
it's not a problem you just trade
everything captures captures you're
gonna play captures captures and now of
course everything ends with captures
and now white is up the exchange you
know in a
well very much a winning endgame so here
after knight captures on e4 we have
rooked the e6 by shankland
and now going definitely after the
knight but now
bishop to g5 putting pressure on the
queen here and here we have
f6 and it looks great the bishop is
under attack the knight is attacked
twice
but again it could not be further from
the truth
so feel free to pause the video and win
this game for magnus well while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations
on uh not uh reacting to the bishop or
the knight or rather to the dark square
bishop and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's bishop the c4 and now uh simply
everything wins for white here
we're just gonna show a really fun line
of what happens if you capture on g5 for
example if if
f captures on g5 uh white goes for
rook to d6 you add another attacker to
the rook because the rook cannot move
either way
and black doesn't have any way of
defending this however
black has this b5 move attacking the
queen and the bishop and it seems black
saves himself but not really rook
captures on e6
not saying okay if you capture the queen
i capture your queen with
check and then everything just falls
apart for black so
queen to d8 but now rook to e8 again
with a discovery here
so you cannot capture because if you
capture then just root captures and
white will have a queen and black will
not
so king to h8 uh black has to do
anything
everything and anything to to capture
white's queen at the end of this line
and finally after rook capture 78 black
will capture the queen but it is uh
simply not enough knight captures on g5
and the white is completely winning
there's no defense uh knight to f7 check
is coming he has a beautiful pass pawn
here
completely winning even if you capture
for example rook captures knight f7
check still wins back the rook
king g8 and now knight captures on the
eighth again with the discovery
for example king of f8 96 will now pick
up the bishop doesn't really matter
the rule comes into the game the
passport is pushed to victory that's
just it
so this was carlson's plan when he
played bishop to c4 however shanghan
said
okay i'm first going to play king to h8
and now the game is still on
but uh bishop captures an e6 by magnus
queen captures an e6 and now just bishop
back to e3
saying this is not a problem because i
always have this so what do you play
here
shanklin did capture on e4 we have rook
captures on d7 and now not the immediate
captures but rather b5
but it's not a problem the queen can
still defend the rook from the d1
square this is the only good move for
white so magnus goes for it queen to d1
and now knight captures on d7 we have
queen captures on d7
now the material is sort of equal magnus
is up only one pawn
but what a pawn it is because here
shanklin played f5 and magnus started
pushing his pawn
c6 bishop to e5 here magnus played c7
and it was in this position that sam
shanklin resigned the game
and yet another victory for magnus
carlsen who after losing to wesley so in
the first round
gets his third win in a row so this is a
round four we'll see what happens in
round five can he continue with with the
streak or will someone
end it and here you resign because
there's nothing to be done
uh you're either queening the pawn and
uh
yeah there's no stopping that if you
play something like queen to b7 to guard
the square then the bishop is still
under attack for example queen e7 goes
after rook and the bishop
you simply cannot defend everything
you're gonna get checkmated very soon
so after c7 shanklin resigned and uh
like i said yet another victory for
magnus carlsen
uh sure uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we'll see what happens in the
last round of of today
i would like to thank massimo sonny bc
david kimura james toynton and howard
gross for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this opera
tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day